ماذا ستكونين هذا العام في
عيد الهالوين؟
ستكونين مشجعة
سييرا سولاك البالغة من العمر خمس سنوات تحب
الأزياء ولكنها لا تمارس لعبة
الخدعة أو الحلوى مثل الأطفال الآخرين الذين يفعلون
أي جراثيم حتى نزلات البرد يمكن أن تقتل
لأنها ولدت مصابة
بنقص المناعة المشترك الشديد أو مرض Bubble Boy الذي
اشتهر من خلال
فيلم جون ترافولتا عام 1976. وُلدت الصبي في الفقاعة البلاستيكية
في هاواي حيث كان والدها
يتمركز كطيار مروحية عسكرية
عندما كان عمرها ستة أيام وتم
نقلها جواً.  إلى مستشفى ماتيل للأطفال في جامعة كاليفورنيا،
حيث أمضت ما يقرب من
شهرين خلال السنة الأولى من حياتها،
ولم تغادر غرفة نومها مطلقًا، وتم
مسح هدايا عيد الميلاد الأولى الخاصة بها وإحضارها
إلى غرفتها لاحقًا، وساعدتها الأدوية في
الحصول على ست إلى سبع جرعات شهريًا
أو إبر في ساقيها  ويمكنها
الخروج ولكن لا تزال غير قريبة من أي شخص باستثناء
عائلتها المباشرة، ثم كان لدى الدكتور دونالد كوهن
الذي يدير هذا المختبر في جامعة كاليفورنيا بعض
الأخبار الجيدة للعائلة التي قال إنها تبدو
وكأنها في المستقبل غير البعيد
ستكون قادرة على الحصول على العلاج
يُسمى العلاج الجيني، لقد عمل عليه
منذ ما يقرب من 40 عامًا، يمكننا حقًا إصلاح
الجين أو استبدال الجين
المفقود، إنه أمر مثير حقًا،
أظهرت دراسة أجريت عام 2021 أن العلاج حقق
نتائج مذهلة شبه مثالية، وجميع الأطفال الذين
عالجناهم في الماضي في حالة جيدة
بالكاد.  لم تعد تسمع منهم ولكن بعد ذلك
قررت الشركة التي تمتلك العلاج بالجينز عدم الحصول على موافقة إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير (FDA)
وبدلاً من ذلك استثمرت الأموال في
علاجات للأمراض الأكثر شيوعًا والتي
تركت سيرشيا وأكثر من عشرين
عائلة أخرى تنتظر الحصول على
العلاج كلما طال انتظارنا
فرصة أكبر للإصابة بالعدوى أو
عدم فعالية الدواء أو
حدوث شيء خارج عن
إرادتنا لجعلها مريضة بشدة. واجهت
العلاجات الجينية الواعدة للأمراض النادرة
أحيانًا صعوبة في
الوصول إلى السوق لأن
الأرباح المحتملة قد تكون صغيرة، لقد كان الأمر
محبطًا للغاية يوم الخميس الذي أعلنت فيه إدارة الغذاء والدواء  عقد
اجتماع حول العلاج الجيني، وهو أحد
سلسلة الاجتماعات العامة التي تهدف إلى المساعدة في
تطوير هذه
العلاجات المبتكرة الأسبوع الماضي، شهد قائد الوكالة
أمام لجنة في مجلس الشيوخ، ونحن متفقون على
أن هذا مجال يتعين علينا التحرك
فيه بسرعة أكبر فيما يتعلق
حصلت عليها ساويرس سانتا في الشهر المقبل،
وستحضر حقيبتها على شكل وحيد القرن إلى
المستشفى للحصول على العلاج الجيني، وكانت قد قامت
بزيارة تحضيرية في وقت سابق من هذا الشهر،
وتتطلع عائلتها إلى اليوم
الذي تكون فيه مثل الأطفال الآخرين في سن الخامسة الذين
تتحمس لهم  تذهب إلى المدرسة
وتريد الذهاب إلى لعبة Dodger وهي
تدعو الجميع إلى عالم ديزني لها
بعد سنوات من الانتظار، يا سيرشا
وعائلتها يشعرون بسعادة غامرة لليوم الذي يمكنها فيه
أخيرًا الخروج إلى العالم